[Musique]
c'est peut-être parce que je suis très
gentil ono avec tout le monde et tout
beau je voudrais que je ressens que leur
mamie gâteau prouve le joli boulot on
espère les voir espère tirer avec ali
n'a carrément pas du biseau il ya quoi
comme chroniqueuse on a la décence de
fermer sa gueule
genre comédie pourquoi sa fraude d'un
trader
il est trop beau mais tombera amoureux
jaloux ah ouais donc pas george clooney
plutôt emma watson à ça je voulu faire
koh lanta je n'ai pas coutume voilà j
sais pas comment on fera pas manger elle
tiendra toujours france aidera pas de
jour où son équipe l'éliminera ou de 12
ça dépend